on va passer maintenant à l'hôtel voilà
qui est le plus traité dans les médias
en ce moment c'est encore les gilet
jaune puisqu'il ya encore un mouvement
qui va être présent samedi donc lamoly
bonne mobilisation se poursuit
aujourd'hui pour la sixième journée
consécutive d'après un sondage publié
hier 70 % des français disent approuver
le mouvement et gilet jaune 40 % des
français disent le soutenir
et bien sûr les médias continuent
d'évoquer l'actualité des gilets jaunes
toute la journée on vous explique tout
ça regardez on va vous dire ce qui va se
passer samedi parce que apparemment j'ai
quelques infos je vous dis voilà il ya
deux trois là ça va être très important
que la semaine dernière regarde après
six jours de mobilisation une partie des
gilets jaunes sont toujours actifs et
continuent de bloquer le pays pour se
faire entendre par le gouvernement tous
les matins frais vassard 6h30
et on ira jusqu'au bout il faut qu'on
bloque l'économie à partir de ce
moment-là peut-être quand commencera à
les écouter
hier le chef de l'état s'est exprimé
devant les 2000 maires de france depuis
l'elysée une conférence durant laquelle
il a fait allusion au mouvement
les responsables politiques ont une
responsabilité inédit mais avec eux je
le dis pour nos amis journalistes qui
sont là les journalistes aussi les
intellectuels à deux jours d'une
nouvelle mobilisation massive qui
devrait avoir lieu samedi
les gilets jaunes ont poursuivi
aujourd'hui leurs actions dans une
partie de la france plusieurs points
stratégiques ont été bloqués dans le
pays dont plusieurs raffineries
aujourd'hui sur le territoire ce sont
près de 77 stations services qui sont à
sec sur l'île de la réunion la
mobilisation bloque toujours lille et
les violences urbaines font plus que
jamais rage depuis samedi dernier
genoa réunion on dirait qu on est des
citoyens
comment ses contours dans le sud de la
france à avignon c'est un barrage monté
par les gilet jaune qui a été forcé par
un automobiliste ce dernier a été pris
en chasse par deux motards de la police
qui ont été contraints de lui tirer
dessus pour le stopper pour contrôler
davantage des rassemblements le
ministère de l'intérieur a indiqué que
les gilet jaune pourrait se rassembler
samedi prochain sur le champ de mars de
son côté la porte-parole des gilets
jaunes a annoncé sur lci qu'elle
refusait d'y manifester préférant se
rendre sur les champs elysées bref c'est
un nouveau week-end mouvementé qui
s'annonce
alors selon vous pourquoi 70 % des
français approuvent le mouvement des
gilet jaune
alors pourquoi 70 % des français
approuvent le mouvement des jets les
jaunes c'est la question qu'on vous pose
aussi chez vous pouvez réagir 1 sur
twitter
bien sûr vous nous dites alors je
voudrais juste dire aussi quelque chose
parce que il ya voilà il ya plein de
gens qui disent 'voilà coûts serrés
qu'on donne la parole au gilet jaune ici
parce que voilà il ya déjà eu des
contradicteurs hier on nous a reproché
de pas d'avoir deux contradicteurs
mardi mardi je vais vous dire comment ça
s'est passé et je vous raconte tout
c'est vrai que j'étais je suis sorti du
studio il ya ces personnes qui m'ont
interpellé qui m'ont dit voilà syrie on
aimerait avoir une tribune sachez qu'ici
tmp voilà on va pas on peut pas donner
une estime tribune à toulouse mais quand
des gens voient là où un message à faire
passer
on essaie de faire passer après qu'on
soit d'accord avec lui ou pas on a
toujours voit là une contradiction
derrière où les chroniqueurs ou mois
pour recadrer ambulance je recadre et la
chose et on a eu les ambulanciers la
dernière fois parce qu'on est une des
seules émissions en direct est une des
seules des missions où ils savent que
l'animateur peut casser complètement le
conducteur voilà donc voilà c'est aux
gens là c'est vrai qu'on fait voilà et
puis on est soudés on est sur l'attitude
on voit là des qui se passe un truc on
peut on peut rebondir à des chroniqueurs
ils ont pas réagi parce que nous on
regarde là des fois on regarde la
pendule 21h ça dépasse et 21h15 voilà
non mais au-delà de ça au delà de ça
c'est vrai que voilà il ya beaucoup de
français qui approuvent donc le
mouvement
après c'est vrai que moi j'ai eu il ya
même des personnes du gouvernement qui
ont réagi qui ont dit qu'ils avaient
peut être contre adducteurs mardi sur
cette séquence
bien entendu on est pas on est on nous
ne veut qu'une chose c'est que tout le
monde puisse s'exprimer
et quelque chose puisse avancer donc on
ice une tribune ici dans cette émission
on en parle pratiquement tous les soirs
parce que c'est là que tu principal du
moment vous pouvez voir que sur toutes
les chaînes info on ne parle que de ça
voilà donc aujourd'hui on voudrait faire
un point sur ce qui va se passer samedi
apparemment il va encore avoir des
choses et emmanuel macron a évoqué les
gilet jaune il a répondu aux questions
des maires à l'élysée hier puisqu'il y
avait le congrès des maires
on regarde tout de suite ce qu'il a dit
emmanuel macron puisqu'il évoque les
gilets jaunes regarde responsables
politiques ont une responsabilité
inédite
mais avec eux je le dis pour nos amis
journalistes qui sont là les
journalistes aussi les intellectuels
quand on ne regarde que la colère et
qu'on fait la promotion que de la colère
avec une forme de fascination morbide
on ne rend pas service à cette colère
légitime alors aujourd'hui la
mobilisation continue en france et vous
allez vous dire ce qui va se passer
samedi parce qu'il ya plein de
téléspectateurs qui se demandent est ce
qui va se passer samedi est ce que ça va
être plus important - l'important est
surtout vous pourquoi les français
soutiennent les gilet jaune à 70%
christine 70% siens jusqu'à légèrement
blessé les aime ils soutiennent parce
qu'ils se sentent représentés
parce que c'est la politique parce que
c'est à syndicats et parce que c'est un
nouveau mouvement qui n'a jamais existé
auparavant et où justement il n'y a pas
de leader donc tout le monde ce sont
justement en complètement représentés du
jamais vu
est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
exactement la conséquence de ce qui
s'est passé politiquement c'est à dire
que emmanuel macron il a renversé tout
le monde politiquement
les syndicats ont explosé l'opposition a
explosé n'existe quasiment plus avec
l'avènement d' emmanuel macron est
aujourd'hui justement on a une nouvelle
nouvelle scène politique et de nouvelles
scènes de mouvement sur le terrain de
mouvement de contestation fort oui oui
sauf que ça se passe partout
enfin ça c'est passé au brésil avec vos
leçons a row ça se passe aux etats-unis
avec tron qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
ça se passe avec le break site
en fait les gens en ont marre en fait
c'est la colère des classes populaires
des classes moyennes et sans de rejet
des élites
alors nous avons dû un nouveau monde et
va finalement les gens d'attendre ce
nouveau monde et ne l'ont pas donc alors
alors c'est normal je vous dis la
mobilisation continue en france vous
l'avez vu regarder et il ya eu quand
même un 2/3 des bordeaux notamment avec
ce journaliste de bfm on va voir la
vidéo dans un instant regard des profits
sixième jour de manifestation ils sont
moins nombreux dans les rues mais il ya
encore des barrages des blocages et des
opérations escargot et certains n'ont
pas du tout l'intention d'arrêter ici à
fontainebleau les personnes mobilisées
continuent de venir très tôt au bord des
routes
on était quand même un petit déjeuner
aux automobilistes il faut qu'on bloque
l'économie à partir de ce moment-là
peut-être qu'on commencera à les écouter
un peu plus au nord dans le calvados les
manifestants s'efforce de prévenir tout
débordement
objectif éviter le moindre amalgame
entre les gilet jaune et les fauteurs de
troubles ce week end une partie des
manifestants ira à paris
mais les gilets jaunes assure que la
mobilisation en région comme ici en
gironde restera forte alors on avec nos
jean claude qui vient pratiquement tous
les soirs matin et toujours chauffeur
vtc tu travailles pas en ce moment j'en
connais pas du tout pas du tout comment
tu vas faire ben tout simplement parce
que là on en a tous marre et donc tu
travailles pas et yacine éviter ce type
de notre collègue on aime tous la marque
voilà qu'est ce qui va se passer samedi
pour les français qui nous regardent et
toutes les personnes qui disent parce
qu'a priori vous dites que le mouvement
va être encore plus important que la
semaine dernière
et du côté des pouvoirs publics on nous
dit que le mouvement ce serait un petit
peu calmé mais voilà oui mais nous ce
qu'on veut et ce qu'on vous redis je le
redis encore ce soir c'est vous dit il
on tourne a tous peur des débordements
on va voir regardez la vidéo qui a eu
avec le collègue de bfm
il ya quand même des mecs qui se
comporte mal voilà on le dit voilà donc
où nous nous le message
on est pour mais quand il ya des
débordements ou quand il ya des choses
comme ça qui se passe sur des collègues
journalistes vous aussi je pense que là
vous vous cautionnez pas regarder bien
l'heure actuelle les forces de l'ordre
vous l'avez vécu en direct viennent de
reprendre la direction de la place de l
étoile au fond de l'image
trouve actuellement du côté de l'avenue
de la grande armée sur cette avenue il
ya eu quelques points de crispation et
de tensions notamment entre certains
gilet jaune et des forces de l'ordre
puisque à de nombreuses reprises des
biens
[Musique]
on va vous rendre à quelques instants
donc vous voyez qu'il ya une tension qui
règne voilà des journaliers d'ailleurs
qu'il sera avec nous demain dans
balances ton post ça c'est pas possible
on claude non non c'est la violence est
inacceptable
voilà maintenant bon c'est vrai que
c'est un mouvement qui va perdurer
pourquoi prenez simplement aujourd'hui
le sénat le may aurait pas de koné en
france où il ya tous les grabataires qui
oppose forme d c'est pour que quand il
fallait pousser pour changer les couches
et les poches urinaires
ils ont voté pour l'ensemble des
français l'augmentation de 40% de des
mutuelles à partir du premier jamais
donc ces voix là c'est encore un pouvoir
d'achat qui va b jean claude là on épand
les voilà pour pas dire juste on
aimerait savoir qu'est ce qui va se
passer dit samedi parce que comme vous
l'a vu voilà 70% des français
soutiennent chute je ne vois là même
s'il y en a beaucoup et on a vu il ya
des commerciaux qui se plaignent parce
que il commence à avoir du mal à
travailler
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui va se passer
exactement c'est quoi le samedi vers
heures au niveau c'est sûr que bon pour
la province de monter à paris ça risque
de coûter cher donc ils vont rester les
y va y avoir des blocages beaucoup plus
massif en province
mais ce qu'ils s'assurent des grandes
places oui sur des grandes places
partout en france contre l'inter routier
entre autres et puis ceux qui vont
pouvoir monter oui ça va être un gros
rassemblement massif sur paris et
certaines manquent pas comme dit le
gouvernement partis comme des moutons au
charme de mars et mai ce sera
certainement aux champs elysées concorde
et pourquoi voulait pas aller au champ
de mars parce que c passable
c'est beaucoup critiqué sur les réseaux
sociaux mais c'est quand même peut-être
plus sécurisé pour vous aussi ses proies
éviter visant là je vous dis non je vais
vous dire c'est pas sécurisé je vous
prends l'exemple preuves ou les pales au
champ de mars est réprouvé vous la
laissez pas tout simplement
samedi dernier nous on a déposé un
préavis samedi dernier on était dans la
rue on était quai de bercy on est allé à
la bastille la préfecture de police n'a
pas respecté l'engagement signé avec la
marianne sur justement sur le préavis de
grève on a été encerclée mais alors plus
con cercle et on a été on a on a été
gazés
alors que nous on était avec les
voitures on avait beaucoup de
de gilet jaune qui voulaient nous
rejoindre ils n'ont pas pu donc dans la
mesure où l'état ne respecte déjà pas ce
droit jean pas pourquoi on respecterait
le droit de voter alors tu peux utiliser
parce que l'air sur mars ils ont fait
des fans zone à la coupe du monde c'est
sécurisé siècle alors et déjà la
concorde on sait que c'est interdit déjà
parvenu hier vers 10 et moi qu'est ce
qui va se passer vous devez vous écouter
déjà le problème qui a c'est que déjà
c'est nous avons des grandes
problématiques
moi je parle en tant que bt c'est parce
que je représente un national de l'union
des vtc on est accablé de taxes et on a
les augmentations programme et c'est
vraiment mais vous reste à la fin du
mois en réalité il ya un rapport qui
existant qui est dans les bacs de la
ministre et des maquereaux aussi jacques
rapoport de jacques rapoport qui évalué
en fin 2016 et début 2010 est à 4h50 net
de l'heure sachant que à l'époque on
avait un carburant un euro 10 h entre
aujourd'hui on est quasiment 1 euro 50
le litre
vous étiez combien avant qu'est ce que
vous voulez mais ne s'était pas à venir
nombreux salindrois dit c'est ça
n'existait pas encore c'est un homme
droit qui nous a fait super longtemps
mathieu banon mais encore une fois
évidemment la cause est très noble pour
mettre un peu les pieds dans le plat
j'aurais bien aussi qu'on arrête de
parler d'un mouvement pacifiste et tout
à l'heure vous dites que les premiers à
dire quand on voit sache c'est très
choquant c'est pas des vrais gilles et
jo ce sont des casseurs et tout ça on en
est selon le figaro aujourd'hui à 2
morts et 5 162 blessés donc je ne peux
pas croire qu'ils aient eu à l'arrêt qui
est autant de mauvaises perfs à la
réunion planqué autant dire aussi
[Applaudissements]
sans blesser deux morts autant dire les
vérités ce n'est pas un mouvement
pacifiste se sont pas que des gens qui
sont isolés qui ont fait des mauvaises
choses au jour lors d'un match qui est
quand même assez le volant à ce concours
est allé vraiment naturel de blessés
dont certains très très grave
non mais nous nous voilà donc à mes
chances que dire mettons donc 2 2 par l
engouement
j'évite gilles mathieu vous pouvez pas
assimiler les débordements au gilet
jaune
c'est comme si vous parlez d'une
manifestation qui a des casseurs et que
vouliez la cause de la manifestation
quand j'entends qu'il essaie d un
débordement giry ça n'a rien à voir
ce sont des gens qui profitent du
mouvement pacifique des jo les jaunes
pour agresser et c'est inacceptable pour
casser et c'est une ajustements regarde
et on a tourné une vidéo regardez kéké
l'inadmissible surya
[Applaudissements]
bon alors de la panique des gens la
panique des femmes ou des hommes en
voiture
alors merci une fois il ya des
variations qu'est ce que vous répondez
on va finir moi là c'est plutôt la
personne qui a foncé dans le tas et on
le voit bien par contre je retiens pas
je ne suis pas sûr monsieur vous pouvez
l'appeler monsieur je reviens pas du
tout parce qu'on parle de mouvement
nous on est ultra pacifiste on essaie de
faire passer des messages vous si vous
me permettez on avait marre cran pendant
la campagne présidentielle qui disait je
préfère un ancien collègue qui était vtc
je préfère avoir des jeunes qui sortent
de cité qui dealent pas et qu'ils
fassent travailler dans des applications
mais qui reste en bas des quartiers et
qui dealent sauf qu'à l'heure actuelle
les chauffeurs sarthe sont sortis des
quartiers mais ils dealent pour des
multinationales qui paient ni taxes
accablé on est en cao n'accablez de
taxes à osséja chinois le coût de
revient ne cesse d'augmenter et nous on
vit une misère ça veut dire que vous
parlez de violence c'est de la violence
sociale qu'on considère que je mets un
cd que j'ai à part quand il ya autant au
temps au temps de me laisser dans
certains très grave
alors j'ai juste vu juste il ya signe
parce que c'est la question c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on vous avait fait venir ce
soir c'est vrai que je me l'a dit 70%
des français soutiennent le mouvement
j'ai aussi parce qu'ils ont peur cyril
beau et beaucoup de gens qui ont peur je
veux dire aussi la vérité pardon de le
dire il ya qu'on a cette émission j'ai
discuté avec des gilets jaunes et après
c'était très discutée dans les loges
mais à très gentil il ya des gens je
verrai pas qui comme on dit fais
attention à ce que tu dis en sortant tu
peux te faire agresser tout ça
les gens ont peur aussi de discuter que
le gilet jaune parce qu'ils ont peur de
se faire massacrer en sentant week end
peur aujourd'hui oui mais de rien mine
de rien et les gilets jaunes aujourd'hui
comme on le dit à chaque fois c'est vrai
que ils essaient de deux évidemment si
réelle passe est évidemment ayant dressé
et madame voilà qui nous font sur une
évidente est alors ceci leur faiblesse
ne pas avoir de 2,2 mais on se dit
comment ça va si les canalise il analyse
je voudrais qu'on voit une autre vidéo
et on espère que ça va bien se passer
samedi alors vraiment je vous le dis est
ce que tout est vous qui êtes un des
représentants est ce que vous pouvez
nous nous rassurer ce que pour rassurer
les français ce que peut leur dire est
ce que ça va bien se passer samedi ou
pas on va tout faire pour que ça se
passe possible je sais qu'il ya un coup
de groupuscules voilà extremis qui se
greffent aussi ce mouvement oui et à
cette manifestation
donc ça quand vous allez faire aussi
mais pour essayer de les aider et de
préserver les français qui sont juste là
qu'on venir manifester et pour venir se
battre pour essayer de faire avancer les
choses
quand on entend christophe castaner
aujourd'hui mise de l'intérieur et je
sais qu'il ya un rapport joue le dit qui
est sorti aujourd'hui qui dit que ça
peut être voilà qui a beaucoup de
groupuscules un peu inquiétant qui vont
manifester samedi pour qu'elle soit
encadrée série oui mais ce que vous
voilà vous est-ce que vous avez vent de
ce qui se passe que vous pouvez rassurer
les gens qui nous regardent et dire
voilà on va tout va bien se passer alors
oui mais pas en fait on pas parce qu'un
vrai donc c'est pas parce que c'est un
mouvement
il n'y a pas de leaders bon nous c'est
vrai que bon on est syndicats vtc donc
nous c'est vrai que les actions que
mènent elles sont structurées elles
n'avaient qu'à réels sont totalement
pacifistes beaucoup de gilet jaune bon
puisque on défend aussi leur cause ils
viennent nous rejoindre
et pourtant bon voilà on va dire voilà
ma de la majeure partie de des français
ont un pouvoir d'achat qui baisse la
plupart se déplace avec hubert et
consorts il cherche le moins cher sauf
que ce qu'ils ne se rendent pas compte
c'est que ce sont des jeunes de cité qui
préfère ne pas être aidé par voilà au
rsa ou autres qu'ont payé que voilà qui
conte payer des voitures qui sont
totalement mais on comprend sa 9 e mail
aboutir mais elles ont peur ce métier
vous apprendra que tu réponds si si si
on prend chacune des questions ne peut
qu'être d'accord avec bien sûr j'allais
gamme très très très forte vous parlez
du carburant détaxé vous payer la taxe
car france paypal attaque sur le un sur
le bal a d'ailleurs dépressifs et des
taxis à la rédaction une arme et moi ce
que je trouve que je trouve que vous
êtes beaucoup de choses vous mettez en
avant il était trop de choses on espère
on espère que ça avance et qu'est ce que
vous attendez de demain de samedi ben de
samedi on attend que le en fait que le
gouvernement
voilà c'était commence à vous écouter on
a vu que ça bouge à peu commencé alors
voila voila c'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire des économies c'est simple je vous
prends un exemple tout cela
on prendra christian levrat devant ses
invités faire ce qu'ils font mais en
attaque 9 janvier c'est à cette époque
qu'est ce que cela tombait à dax en
janvier qui va arriver là la double
peine salengro l'enlever 3 milliards
c'est que 5 centimes ça représente
honoraires sur un on aura balancer mon
66 à 65 sur la france en colère on aura
plein de témoins je vous le dis on va
voir si vous vous approuvez mouvement et
gilet jaune
oui à 62 % nous à 38% c représente un
petit peu le dernier sondage qui est
sorti aujourd'hui je vous le dis nous on
espère que ça va aller mieux pour vous
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a donné à park
la scène vous m'avez interpellé
j'espère que ça bouge en tout cas ce que
je vois c'est que vu ce que vous faites
et se mouiller dans les médias et votre
mettrons-nous maintenant votre discours
votre discours plus pacifiste commence à
intéresser le gouvernement et les fait
bouger
donc vous êtes sûr vraiment si vous êtes
sur le bon chemin samedi fait tout pour
que tout se passe bien et je pense que
ça va bouger dans le bon sens pour vous
en tout cas je l'espère où j'avais dit
dans la foi j'avais dit on entre
parenthèses voile entre guillemets on
aurait pu être le porte parole et gilet
jaune je parle pas de porte parole cité
voilà en tout cas si on peut être les
médiateurs ici dans cette émission parce
qu'on est une émission populaire on est
une émission où les gens qui nous
regardent
moi ils me disent dans la rue me dit
cyril notre dernier loisirs c'est la
télé voilà parce qu'ils n'ont plus rien
ils n'ont plus donc c'est à dire merci
sincèrement entre vous et le
gouvernement et on sait que mine de rien
cette émission est très regardée et même
voilà voilà je vous dis mamie dans les
plus hautes sphères et même à l'elysée
et bien cette mission a commencé à faire
bouger les choses et on vous commencez
je pense à dialoguer un petit peu avec
le gouvernement et le chef de l'état
nous ce qu'on veut c'est que tout se
passe bien et je vous le dit voilà je
vous le dis franchement le chef de
l'état et le gouvernement
on en dispose veut mais ça leur fait pas
plaisir non plus moi j'ai emballé j'ai
eu des robes des représentants du
gouvernement
ça ne leur fait pas plaisir aussi de
vous voir dans la rue de vous voir
malheureux et ils vont essayer de faire
bouger les choses il faut ça se passe
bien et il faut que ça se passe dans un
état
dans la rétine voilà